SPEAKER: Google Maps
offers you a wealth of data
for building
location-aware apps.
Let's take a look at a solution
for location-aware apps,
a transport tracker.
This gives you a
complete solution
for understanding where your
various vehicles, such as buses
or trucks, are at
any given time.
What does a system for
transport tracking look like?
Well, first of all, there
are the vehicles themselves.
You need to understand how
to report on their location,
how to store their
location in a database,
and get real-time updates
from that database.
How to display the
vehicle locations
on a map, how to style
that map, and how
to administer the whole system.
The Transport Tracker
solution will teach you
how to build all of this,
including the map where
all of your assets
are, a mobile app that
reports on the location
of the vehicles,
and the back end that
ties everything together.
In particular, the back end
receives real-time updates
of the vehicle locations and
sets up the display panels
for use by the front end.
You'll learn through
tutorials and documentation,
with a full reference
implementation in open source.
With this, you'll have
the basis for building
any kind of asset-tracking
solution using
the full suite of tools
available for Google Maps.
Learn more at developers.googl
e.com/maps/solutions.